new in theaters this weekend motherless
brooklyn harriet and terminator dark
fate what will you see this is your
weekend ticket
[Music]
i get something wrong with me that's the
first thing to know i got threads in my
heads
i got threads in my heads man i twitch
and shout a lot
makes me look like a damn freak show can
you ever cut that out
touch it bailey i'm sorry but inside my
head's an even bigger mess
i can't stop twisting things around
words and sounds especially have to keep
playing with them until they come out
right
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
jeez i figured i asked when a detective
with tourette's loses his partner to
murder he decides to find out who did it
by finding a woman his partner was
investigating unfortunately he starts
realizing
he's uncovered more than he bargained
for the movie is based on the
award-winning novel of the same name
and the film is written produced and
directed by edward norton
who also stars in it in case you're
closing your eyes for the footage we've
been showing
please don't do that this movie is for
you if a hard-boiled crime drama sounds
good to you
you're looking forward to edward norton
taking the helm once again
or if you think this scene makes a great
anti-smoking campaign
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
jeez i figured i asked you got to be
miles away from here where is she
follow that north star if they're no
stars
just follow the river listen for them
fear is your enemy whoa
easy now i'm gonna be freaking down
harriet is the story of famous
abolitionist harriet tubman who famously
and heroically
escaped slavery and went on to free 70
other slaves
via the underground railroad the film
stars cynthia arrivo as harriet tubman
as well as leslie odom and janelle monae
whose album dirty computer is
this movie is for you if a historical
biography sounds good this weekend
you're down to get inspired or you're
hoping janelle monae drops make me feel
at some point in the movie
[Music]
um
terminator dark fate is the third movie
in the james cameron terminator series
that's right chronologically it goes
terminator terminator 2 judgement day
and terminator dark fate this time
there's a new terminator in town the
rev9
bent on killing a new character named
danny ramos
but with the help of a mysterious woman
from the future sarah connor and a t-800
they just might have a chance to protect
the future this movie is for you if
you're looking for a sci-fi
action flick this weekend you're a fan
of the original two terminator
movies or if you're trying to it's
producer scott from the future
just wanted to let you know that next
week's weekend ticket
is about last christmas
next weekend's last last christmas is
next
the movie last christmas it comes out
next
next week next next week the last
get out of here future scott confusing
me from the future
i got this that is your weekend ticket
what will you see and come back next
week for sleep fire and christmas
[Music]
you